everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse and this is my coworker
Adam so my hands not in the picture they
were I have to do it the opposite way
they yeah it is confusing to get the
directions right but anyway yeah so he
works with me here at Franciscan
University and he is a writer so you
want to say what's up
I mean apparently like within the next
10 years like computers are gonna be
able to do what I do so but for the time
being like I yeah I write stuff and yeah
what's up everybody
Ohio River Valley the loveliness of May
that's great
it is nice and May yeah cool if anyone
is big country music fan I feel you
really know if anyone is on your podcast
but I don't know nobody likes country
music let us know in the chat or in the
comments if you're watching this either
on okay see Don you mean him a real cool
so yeah but anyways I'm out lovely to
meet you all all right cool thanks Adam
all right so I gave my Spotify on before
we start I am in the office today as you
might realize from the background and
yeah so that was Adam and he's I think
he's the newest addition to the team so
he he's been here for I don't know if
it's been a year yet but he's been here
for a while but he's he's one of the
newer people so yeah and I'm not a
country music fan so I'm not exactly
sure who he was talking about when he
said he had the hook-up so but if you
all know then I guess you you understand
but today we're going to work on that
same component that we were working on
yesterday so yesterday we had mentioned
you know probably a few times that it
would be great to get some other pieces
of data and not have to actually go in
and manually edit the data so I decided
you know afterwards like hey you know
what that that it would probably be
better to just do what we have to do in
the component to just pull in that mass
of HTML and probably poorly formatted
HTML and just pick out the pieces of
data that we need and use those that
that would take probably much less time
not only for that particular use case
but when we do that I I'm almost
positive we'll find some other use cases
where with just a few adjustments the
same bit of code that we write today
hopefully if it works will also work and
save us a lot of time elsewhere because
we're talking about in terms of
WordPress posts I mean we're talking
about hundreds and hundreds if if not
into the thousands of posts so if we
spend an hour today
writing something that can save us from
editing I don't know even a hundred
posts or less that's definitely worth
our time so I am working on getting some
student workers to come in and maybe do
some manual editing of the data you know
to help out so that we don't have to do
all kind of this weird stuff in our
components to work with it but for right
now this is what we have I can't count
on that it's a it's a busy time for
students so I'm not that hopeful that
we'll get them they're all taking their
finals now and their students are
graduating this weekend so may or may
not happen I do have one student intern
but he's working he and some of his
classmates are working on a totally
different section of the site so I
they're already busy with that I don't
want to add more to what they're doing
okay
Oh before we start so yeah I'm just
gonna take another minute tell you all
about one more thing and and that way we
may get some more viewers here for some
reason we're down lower lower than our
normal count I'm not sure what happened
with that but I just want to let you
know let me get it up on the screen here
and let me switch views okay so I want
to let you know about JavaScript AF and
I'll put I'll put the linked directly in
the free code camp chat here so this is
a project I'm not doing it for my main
job at the University this is a side
project that really a lot of you came up
with the idea so just to give you a tiny
overview of this a while back I had the
idea to check to see if there were any
dot AF domain names that might be worth
buying and JavaScript AF was available
so I bought it and then I asked on
Twitter and on Instagram and I believe
on the show what should I do with this a
domain name now that I bought it and
someone on Twitter I can't remember
their name but I need to go back and
look it up because they deserve a lot of
the credit someone on Twitter said why
don't you use it too and I'm
paraphrasing here but to highlight
different JavaScript projects that are
really cool that are happening in the
community and I thought that was a
wonderful idea also had JavaScript her
on Instagram saw it and had had some
other ideas as well so we ended up at
first combining all the ideas and it was
this massive undertaking and then we
decided to maybe split that up and break
it down to its core so at its core it's
a way to share awesome JavaScript
repositories with each other and and to
search for these cool JavaScript
repositories so that's that's what it is
maybe we'll have more features later on
we'll just kind of see how it goes but
anyway since this was kind of like born
out of collaboration between you all
know the whole community around this
stream I thought it'd be cool to just
bring it up explain that a little
and let you all know that you could
check it out you can log in with your
github profile and add your own repos to
this get some exposure for your
repositories check out what some of the
other people were doing and you can also
go to the github page for this and
contribute it's entirely open source so
if you would like to be involved in the
project you know please do so that would
be that would be really awesome so we
have a lot of open issues that at least
we did have it I think we still do I
haven't I haven't checked the issues yet
today so here actually we do we do have
some issues so let me copy and paste the
repository link as well so that's the
link repository on github and yeah so
I'm gonna stop talking about that since
that's not really the title of the video
but just want to throw that out there
and I really hope that this turns into
something that is useful for the
community so it's going to be a free
thing if it starts getting big we're
gonna try to work out some ways to pay
for the servers and stuff right now I'm
just paying for them video personally
but for now at least it's entirely free
I just wanted I just wanted to have be
something cool for for you all for the
whole community so anyway let's go on to
see what we did yesterday trying to find
English faculty what is wrong canonical
class as a function
what a great way to start the stream
it's already broken what did I do
let's restart the server I did pull down
all the changes that we made yesterday
and let's do a hard refresh
all right well now let's let's check out
the air then I guess so faculty list
like to cannot call class as a function
all right let's check it out
faculty list j/s yeah that doesn't make
any sense
out
No
all right let's see what we're we're
doing
Oh also hey everybody I noticed a lot of
you were saying hi in the end the chat
let me let me start my Pomodoro timer
and as soon as that finishes I'll go to
the chat I'll check out your questions
to answer as many as I can
what's so for those of you who watch
yesterday this definitely worked
yesterday right so we had it working and
now let me see actually let me take this
I think this call is gonna be about the
project so let me take this hello pretty
good are you doing
I could I could talk quickly is that
okay okay mm-hm
mm-hmm
mmm-hmm
okay yeah yeah for sure that's yeah we
have some kind of bolder button styles
that we have available so definitely I
think I'm I'm gonna meet with with
Steven later today yeah yeah okay yeah
and the only the only reason about the
San Damiano thing is on a previous site
there was kind of a big deal about do we
use the San Damiano cross in outline in
such a way I think it was on my bullet
points and the decision was made that no
like we're not gonna use it as bullet
points if we use it it'll be like the
the image and not utilitarian any in any
way so I figured I can't use it now even
if we wanted to because you know the for
the people that worked on the previous
project that wanted to use it they would
immediately if they saw I'd say well why
couldn't we do it
all right yeah Oh awesome thank you oh
that's great I really appreciate that
you too right all right so sorry about
that I do I'd like to take calls during
the stream because this is supposed to
my my real work so especially if I know
the call is gonna be about the project
that we're working on I like to take it
that way y'all can hear how I interact
with other people at the office and I
can give you a recap of what we just
talked about so that was the director of
missionary outreach so our students go
on spring break and on various holidays
our students go on mission trips to
various poor communities throughout the
United States and throughout the world
and they'll do things like teach and
take care of children at orphanages and
help feed the poor and all different
kinds of charitable activities so he
organizes all of that and the section of
the website that's gonna deal with that
we have my intern and several other
students are working on that section so
I haven't talked directly with the
director yet it's always been a
go-between between the students meet
with him and then the students meet with
me so the director just called me to
discuss one option about their his kind
of idea for one section of the site and
so basically the what it was is I had
rejected that idea and it offered an
alternate solution and he was happy with
that and I was just explaining like why
why we couldn't go with with that idea
so I guess from that I just want to say
like don't be afraid to be firm with
your design principles that you're using
and not compromise them and in this case
there was no conflict it was here's why
I don't want to do it like that here's
an option that'll be good and
and really he shared the reason why he
wanted to do it like that and I think we
could accomplish that same thing in a
different way and I think it'd be even
better a better user experience so he
was fine with that
and the call ended with him saying you
know thank you for all your work the
site looks awesome really excited about
it
so anyway doesn't always go that
smoothly but you know it
I guess just don't be afraid of
potential conflicts you know over design
especially designed user experience like
if you know that what you want to do is
the better way to go don't be afraid to
stick up for it it may not even result
in a conflict so I mean it's good to be
flexible on things that really don't
matter and then kind of save it for the
things that do in this case this
definitely did matter this was a
decision they wanted to use the outline
of the San Damiano crucifix which isn't
it isn't our logo here but it's an image
that's used frequently if you remember
the catechetical Institute project we
use that that image of the crucifix on
on the homepage and they wanted to use
the outline of it as a button to donate
so it would essentially be the outline
of that with the word donate in it and
that would be a button and we had
decided on a catechetical Institute
project that we weren't going to
instrumentalize the crucifix in that way
being a sacred object for catholics and
orthodox we didn't want to do that
so i that was something that I
definitely didn't want to budge on it
was also something from a user
experience standpoint that I thought
would be confusing to users nowhere else
on the site do we have a button that's
designed like that at all I figured
users probably wouldn't even realize
that it was a button and was able to
click on so it didn't have any precedent
at all in anything we've done before or
in material design and it would be
confusing to the user so so for a lot of
those reasons I had to be firm on that
but anyway so sorry to go off on a
little tangent
those sorts of things I think are
important to go over because you don't
often get those in code tutorials that
are just about the code but this job
isn't always just about the code it's
it's frequently about interaction with
clients co-workers and things like that
so having a product you can feel proud
of sometimes isn't just about your skill
as a coder you have to be able to
influence others to accept decisions you
make the right decisions so I've worked
on projects before where it's at the end
of the project I don't put my name on it
there's no link to my website in the
project because I couldn't be proud that
the decisions that were made by the
client I was not in agreement with
so I did it but I'm not gonna say that's
my website I wouldn't deny it if
somebody asked but so anyway I just
that's an important it's important skill
that's often overlooked it's just not
even thought of as as being a part of
building something good but I really
think it is on almost all of my projects
it definitely would not have been as
successful as it was if I had just gone
along with whatever the people around me
and above me suggested so especially if
you're kind of in a position that I am
where I'm one of the very few web
developers that work here I have to
remember like I I am the expert on this
subject matter so while it might be
someone higher up in the organization
sometimes vice presidents of the
organization they're giving their
opinion but that's not their subject
matter so very respectfully it's
definitely up to me as the expert to say
we're not I don't think we should do it
that way here's why and unless the
person is very egotistical then they're
going to respect they're gonna respect
that as long as you can give a good
answer and usually I like to base it on
data like
you know the analytics show that if we
do it this way we'll get more clicks
more clicks equals more students more
donors like then it goes well you know
you got to know your stuff but anyway
sorry
enough of the sidetrack here I may have
already used up my time I don't know
what my timer is we're gonna go oh I'm
still 15 minutes we'll keep this time
we're going let's check out why this
doesn't work maybe I'll check another
let me check something else let's go
with Fine Arts no it still doesn't work
all right let's just try another pitcher
so I'm pretty sure English has a page
okay so that works
it's just when I try to do faculty it's
not working okay so obviously like this
is giving me the line for the Distan
like the bundled version is file which
is not very helpful to me let's go can I
go farther down and will it tell me
you know let me just fine
you know call class as a function
you know I should check the live chat to
see if any of you have any insight on
the air Oh Frankie I see a lot of what
you were saying about that it's helpful
to hear what I was just talking about
thank you for saying that I'm always not
sure what's most helpful to you also I
really appreciate that feedback
okay I didn't look like anybody has any
ideas yet sorry if I missed it
all right so class cannot call class as
a function so I don't think this is
going to do anything but
I'm really at a loss here you all were
witnesses yesterday that this works who
would we ended the stream yes hey what
is different all right let me let me
check to make sure the pool was
successful so here's I did the get pool
updating I faculty this side and that's
what we worked on faculty the faculty
list yes yeah I mean these look like the
files that we work with yesterday it
pulled down that code of conduct as well
created that faculty this item J yes hmm
I let's check out our faculty list item
because I know the error is is saying
it's in this page maybe but it maybe
it's farther down and we're just not
seeing it
okay I should says try nuking node
modules and re yarn oh good idea let's
do that good idea I don't know why I
always forget that hard this is
like the second time this week you
reminded me that that's a possible
solution and hopefully it'll work
alright so if you need to get rid of
your node modules the easiest way I know
of to do it is to RM RF the node modules
do not do this command unless you are
absolutely sure that you want to get rid
of these files once you do this anything
in the folder or any subfolders and any
files in any of those folders will be
gone and you cannot get them back they
don't go in the trash they're gone okay
so with that warning I'm about to do it
so I'm gonna say RM and then given our
RF flag and then I will say node modules
so now let me turn the server off so
doesn't freak out okay so if I try to go
to let's say CD node modules it doesn't
exist I'm trying to tab over there it's
not Auto completing so it's gone now I'm
gonna run yarn and it's gonna rebuild
all those modules so for this machine
it's probably not going to take that
long if you have an older computer this
may take longer if you have a non
reliable internet connection probably
not a good idea to do so just kind of a
little a little warning if you need to
get something done you might want to try
a different method to fix it this is
like I don't know for me this is like
when something doesn't work on a Windows
computer and you just reinstall windows
like this it's like wow I don't really
know what the problem is so let's just
reset everything
right while that's doing its thing I'll
check out a few things in the live chat
just some of the latest stuff that
popped up Mme says hey long time no see
how are you I'm doing pretty good how
are you I'm glad to see you back in the
in the chat whoa that was so fast that
was less than a minute awesome okay so
let's restart the server and see if it
works for this particular project we use
the command yarn dev may not be the same
depending on what you're using for your
project but for next J s projects dev is
pretty standard alright it's refreshing
it's refreshing refreshing no ah okay
are we getting a different error it's no
it's exactly the same error
shoot I guess I ought to just read this
it's kind of avoiding actually reading
all of this but now maybe I'll read a
little bit more and see if I can find
out what what's happening
all right that's that's not helping me
at all I don't know if you all saw
anything all right
so let me see you check the network I
want to see I'm gonna refresh this and
see if if anything happened like did did
an actual request get made
nah whoops
okay
let's see John says I wonder if you may
have placed your component as a child
argument into another component if the
child is a class it can't work if it is
written as an argument all right
I'm not I'm not exactly following that
train of thought I don't know maybe John
can you explain it to me maybe pretend
maybe you don't have to pretend that
much but pretend like I have no idea
what I'm doing you explain it to me
please
all right you know what I didn't check
out any of our other components that we
change so let's do that now as well let
me get rid of some of these
my components of here faculty was that
oh I should saw the error export see
with stylus of parentheses you have open
and close them
okay cool
I'm pretty sure this is what I I did in
this work yesterday after I did this
I thought I tried to do in a different
way it didn't work then I looked up how
we did it on in a different page what
page was that was it the index
no I doubt it was the index I mean it's
worth looking at but yeah that's nothing
I don't think it was the search fish
proof
I see
okay ref ref all let me know if I
mispronounce that but thank you for that
so Rafal thinks it was majors or major
yes awesome what a good memory thank you
okay so here's how we did it oh okay all
right so I it looks like I did do it
wrong so let's check so we have one open
front the second one here one open one
open and and I shouldn't have it I
shouldn't have closed it I should have
closed it there I should have closed it
here
that's really odd I mean I thought it
worked I I don't know I don't know what
happened unless I somehow have my
editors set differently with Auto
formatting and it messed it up I don't I
don't know I mean I guess we'll find out
if we if we try to commit this and it
formats it weird but I don't know it
doesn't make sense
anyway this works so everybody that that
caught that thank you so much all right
Wow and we're almost the end the
Pomodoro session so I'm just gonna start
answering questions take a five-minute
break answer questions that'll be good
cuz I can relax my brain for a second
from trying to figure out that error and
I just realized I don't have my light on
there we go
when we come back then we'll come back
to this and start doing what I had hoped
we would be doing but that's that's cool
that happens that's because that's life
that's how it happens sometimes so I'm
really glad that I decided to work on
this during the stream today because you
you all were very very big help and
potentially save me a lot of time
alright let's start this whoops
short break I'm scrolling all the way up
to the top and I'm just gonna work my
way down through as many questions as I
can and anything I don't get now I'll
get after the next Pomodoro session
okay Christian asked if I still use the
dev Franciscan dot University yes let me
let me put that in there dev all right
so I just put that in the live chat if
you want to check out this site the
development version go to dev da
Franciscan University at some point
today if I can remember I'd like to
update that with the latest changes so
right now it's it's a like maybe a week
behind in terms of what we've been doing
on the stream so I'd like to update it
soon thanks for reminding me about that
Christian
Frankie says greetings as how you don't
want hope all as well not bad I'm
feeling really happy today actually I
mentioned last week or so that I was
going on a diet and exercising and so
far I felt I felt a lot better
definitely more energy in the morning
I've lost seven pounds so I mean it's
it's it seems like it's going really
well
and I don't know I mean you know
everybody always says if you eat healthy
and you exercise you'll feel better and
I always hope that they were wrong
because I'd like to eat donuts all the
time and and I don't know like just I'd
like to eat anything I want to eat right
but over the last two weeks it's
definitely been my experience that I do
feel a lot better so unfortunately it is
true if you want to feel good and have
energy you gotta exercise and eat right
that makes me so sad but it's true
yeah-ha-ha I just read her should have a
comment in here it's let's see what
we've done yesterday then good old next
yes error page maybe laugh at I'm I'm
glad that it made you laugh
yeah that's outer eyes just how it is
sometimes
[Music]
jayson's notice it's a hard line the
phone yeah so the phone in my office is
actually connected with the cord they
still exist
anybody who's really young and watching
this this is how all phones were at one
time when I was little I remember we had
a really long cord so that my mom could
walk all the way around the house and do
stuff and still be on the phone so yeah
so those are the folks that we have sure
sure ah sorry if I'm pronouncing that
wrong Shura says what are all the live
streams that free cocaine does I do most
of the live streams occasionally we do
have some other people live stream as
well I think Ethan Arrowwood did some
live streams he hasn't done one in a
while though so I'm not sure if he's
planning on doing anymore or not
so yes pretty much I I believe it's
pretty much just me and most of our
other videos are pre-recorded at this
point so unfortunately it's just me so
if you if you don't like my style I
guess there's not another option for you
right now but if you'd be interested in
doing something like this for free code
camp reach out to beau Carnes or Quincy
and you know propose something you might
be able to do some streams as well or
videos ronan says hello hey Ronin how's
it going thanks for watching
Frankie I'm just seeing all your
messages when I was talking about the
phone call that I had thank you so much
for all the encouragement I don't know
if you realize how much that that helps
me and motivates me to keep going and
just I mean honestly just makes me feel
really good so thank you so much I
appreciate that
okay so my times up I want to write down
where I'm leaving off in the chat so I
can go right back to it afterwards okay
I've written that down and let's see let
me start this wonderful now I can tell
you what I was going to tell you at the
very beginning of the stream it's taking
me a bit longer than I thought but
here's the page we're going to be
working on we want to make it look nicer
here's the data that I really want to be
here I want an image of these particular
faculty members and I also want their
title I want that to be like the minimum
data that we display at some point later
on maybe we'll display more but right
now I think that's bare minimum because
that's what's already on the website the
the current website that we'll be
replacing so let's let's get to it we
need to we need to see the data first to
figure out how we're gonna get it so let
me go into WordPress and log in and
we'll go to faculty and we'll pick I
guess I'll go in here to classics I'll
go to uh Sarah where because she's a
really cool person and I know her my
wife knows her a lot better than I do
but I saw her when I was in the back of
church with my kids one Sunday cuz the
baby was making a fuss
she had her newborn baby back there and
she was super nice so I'm gonna feature
her today
we want to get this and it's inside a
title tag which is great because we
should be able also awesome I am super
happy about this so we can focus on
finding this title tag and then get the
data out of here and use that as the
title I just glanced at the chat and so
Frankie ass is is your wife a coder she
is so she actually did teach in the
English department which I was just
showing she was an adjunct so she didn't
show up on the website but she taught
there she just taught her last class
last week and now she is learning to
code she's been learning for a few
months and she was with me at the Google
i/o conference just the extension
conference in Pittsburgh and she's she
works now for moms can code which is a
nonprofit to help moms learn how to code
so she's teaching a course on blockchain
development with solidity so really cool
she really likes it so far of course
I've been encouraging and and we were up
before the kids got up this morning
working on code and so that's been fun
and she actually has a blog too so it's
it's on github I should I should link it
after somebody remind me after this
Pomodoro session is over and I'll paste
in the link to my wife's blog because
she blogs about coding related stuff and
she built her own blog as well so we can
get title where's there's the image that
we want okay so we have two different
images one is supposed to be a smaller
image and the other one is supposed to
be a larger image assuming that they
were all put in correctly
into the old system which I don't know
if they were or not actually we we could
probably grab this entire image tag so
we could just say anything that's inside
this list view image we can grab the
whole thing we'll see if this image
works if it's too small then we'll grab
this detail view image okay let's see
all right so I this is actually doable I
was worried that it would be really hard
but this seems doable I do want to check
I think we have some code and other
components that can help us get a jump
start on this so let's find what
component already has some of this stuff
in here and then we'll we'll try to use
that so I'm gonna leave this up on this
screen but jump over here quickly what
screen is it you know what maybe it's
the profile
oh no that's where's the should be
faculty is a faculty okay there we are
so you can see in this page we're doing
some searching for for content hmm and
in this case we are removing removing
things and putting in okay so actually
we ought to keep
okay we got to keep some of this
countenance retirees
hmm
all right well let's just let's start
into it and see see how far we can get
so in our we'll do this in our faculty
list should we are we passing in content
factor this item profiling profile link
content okay we can pass in content I
guess we'll do it here in this component
I think that makes more sense to do it
here okay so let's make sure we pass in
the content and
content
okay let's save that
uh-huh Aniki noticed again that I have
this global X content which was just in
there for testing and I keep forgetting
to remove it everywhere so good catch on
that like I don't I see it and it just
doesn't occur to me at all to take it
out I don't know what's wrong with my
brain it's just it's it's like it's it's
not even there
okay all right so now we're done with
this and then we're going to be working
here in our faculty list item component
by the way if I haven't said it already
all of this code that we're working with
is available on github the links in the
description it's all open source feel
free to use any of it for any purpose
you want I mean try not to use it for
anything bad but I really can't stop you
okay so what we want to do then is take
the content and we're gonna manipulate
it to get what we want from it so we're
not exactly going to do it like this
where we create a constant called
content we're gonna split it up because
we're basically going to want image and
then we'll want a constant called title
and we'll split it up like that so you
know what let's just copy
listen let's copy a bunch of this stuff
here and in the context of faculty j/s
this is this is in a different place
than we're gonna put it here because
we're doing different things this is
inside a query component so this is a
little bit different so let's see what
we can put this
I believe we can put it right here and
that would be a decent spot for it so
let's just say let's call this one image
and let's call this one title and here
we can take out all of this stuff and
just say content and we can also do that
here so let's take this we're getting
these red lines here because we haven't
used it yet so it's it's fine once we
use it down here and our component it
should work so let's see what's
happening this replaced details we can
get rid of that but before I completely
take it out I'd like to see if we could
just adjust it to do what we want so
let's go back and look so basically what
this is doing is finding the tag called
details and then replacing it with a
different tag so I don't think that
that's really what we want to do here so
we're not gonna do that now you know
what let me let's let's check out an
article on MDN why it should be sort of
this JavaScript I don't remember exactly
what this returns when we do search but
this might be what we want if we notice
with us in the sky
the index to the first match between the
regular expression and they give a
string if not found on okay so it will
return weight will turn the index of the
first match I don't really want the
index what I want testaments shame or
information with sufficient use of a
match returns for yeah I don't want the
index okay so let's check match and
let's see I'm just checking the chat
really quickly usually if I'm heading
down the wrong path in my research then
you all let me know so that's who I
wanted to double-check I see a lot going
on in the chat so that's awesome I can't
wait to to check it out after this
Pomodoro session I clicked the wrong
thing okay if you're not familiar with
mdn it's the Mozilla developer Network
and it's always like maybe the first or
second thing that comes up in a google
chat when you look up JavaScript stuff
and other stuff too but I find it to be
one of the best resources if you really
want to get to know what certain thing
does alright so this will return the
string match deficient we're turning an
array containing the entire match string
as the first element followed by any
results captured in parentheses if there
were no matches null is returned okay
let's see the examples alright so here
they've they made a variable called
fountain and that equals string here so
this string and then they've matched it
with this regular expression so the log
shows string which is C chapter okay
actually I sent you for more information
okay
all right I think this will work so if
anybody knows of a better method to use
maybe something more performant I'm open
to that as well but for now I think
we're going to use this and this this
should work okay so let's see a non
rigid object all right so let's grab all
right
oops wrong way here we go so let's get
rid of this I want to keep the replace
though so we're gonna do dot match and
what we want to match is let's see let
me look back here I'm not I don't have
regular expression stuff you know all
memorized so I always have to look it up
so let's go with what is this supposed
to be image detail I need to look at
what this was I can't remember what it
was exactly
okay so I'll list view image that's what
we were gonna use
all right so ListView image and let's
see we want to end
anybody good with regular expressions
help me out here let me explain what I
want and then help me out if you can
otherwise I'm gonna have to look up the
correct syntax here which is okay I'm
not complaining about that but I just
want to use you all as resources if I
can so what I'd like to do is let me go
back to here to visa so I'd like to get
all the data that is between this
opening ListView image tag and this
closing ListView image tag so that's
what I'd like to do let's see
drinks every are so I said read reg reg
X which is for from regular expression
fine string between two strings Menace
over to match all characters between two
strings let's see
extract string area extract string
between two strings that's what we want
okay
No look behind is not supported in
JavaScript am I not gonna be able to use
this then
let's see Michael says this is what I
was going to play around with yesterday
I thought you're gonna get the intern to
do it
Oh what I was gonna do with the intern
is I was going to get the intern to
manually edit the data so that we didn't
have to do this so but then I decided
well like number one I don't really the
intern is working on other stuff and
then number two it would probably be
better if I just do this because most
likely have to apply it to other cases
as well all right so I need to try to
make sense of this matches a percent
character okay so this is a look behind
okay
maybe won't be able to use this because
this isn't supported in JavaScript they
have to find another one I'll leave it
up just in case but let's see it so much
every character between this is a sent
in synthesized it's still it's using the
look behind included fuse cases
hmm
all right let's try
let's try this
okay yeah this show that
oh okay John says if you use style
components you can bring in the whole
string you set a Const for your element
name which is the element and nest the
image in the CSS styling this can all be
wrapped and material huh that's
interstate hmm skewed all right let's
let me throw this in quickly and then I
will need
you look at the end in I can't use you
use this to escape this ring
this team image
it's an expression
we'll see some stuff
all right I saw some stuff pop up in the
chat I wondered if it was about this but
looks like our just came back so
welcome back our
what am I missing
initiation
let me check that mdn see what that one
alright said they have all I regular the
regular expressions as separate
variables I mean I guess I could try it
like that if that's
I said I want it I check again
okay
again
Oh
I don't know what I was thinking I could
probably move this back in here actually
let me put it back in you
oops I mean back in here Wow why can't i
okay I do this right here
wait a second oh I I highlighted
everything there we go
okay all right so what I'm doing then
and now I do I want to replace or I want
to add in Franciscan dotty to you for
now and let's throw in image
i order that the invalid regular
expression let's so let's do another
break I'll go back answer some more
questions and then we'll work on this
there's something wrong with my regular
expression syntax so I think as soon as
we figure that out it should work so may
not need a whole nother Pomodoro session
for that okay so I'm going to go back up
to where I left off
in the live chat and answering questions
Aurra or era I'm not sure how to
pronounce this ara it says what editor
is this it's Visual Studio code
okay himemiya says earlier I asked the
many how he was no one in then I didn't
get a chance to read their Swan so
the responses says thanks I want to say
that lately I have been accepted in a
Google Africa scholarship for mobile web
specialists at Udacity if you can tell
us your option about these online
certificates oh yeah for sure
I think the Udacity courses are great
you learn a lot in terms of the actual
certificate and its value it's entirely
dependent on a company and what the
company thinks so if a company has
already hired people from Udacity they
will probably depending on how those
employees worked out they will probably
have a higher opinion of a nano degree
certificate from Udacity otherwise you
just you never know no one at the
company may have heard of Udacity before
and you know maybe they're skeptical of
it so it's not a guarantee at every
company but you can check out a company
on LinkedIn and it should tell you you
should be able to see how many people
went to Udacity so I think if you have
Udacity listed as a school in your
LinkedIn profile when you look at
companies profiles or at least their job
listings it should tell you how many
other people from Udacity got hired and
work at that company now it's imperfect
measurement because there could be
people from Udacity that work at that
company that don't have get up profiles
so you you may not get 100% accurate
results but that should at least let you
know like the company hired ten people
from Udacity you know maybe they know
what's up you know that Udacity is a
good place to work but my feelings are
about it or like you you learn a lot if
you're the type of person that does well
when an hour
with our deadlines and structure I think
it's a great great way to learn you know
the cause if you have a scholarship it's
great because to me the only downside to
Udacity is is paying for it when there
are so many great free resources out
there it's really hard to commit to
paying for a program so I think the
scholarship thing is wonderful my wife's
working through the front-end nanodegree
right now she also got a scholarship so
and I did the react nano degree I didn't
get a scholarship I just paid for it but
yeah so I I definitely do recommend it
assuming that it works within your
budget and your financial situation
hater says what is the best way to
handle media queries with react that is
a great question
let's take a look quickly at how we
handle it here so in in particular we
can go in the component right we we have
media queries here well if you're using
a framework like material UI they may
have ways to do media queries so
materialise way to handle media queries
here is they have these break points or
we can do theme break points and then up
and it you know extra large screen so
basically this allows us to mimic the
functionality of media queries when
using CSS in within our component also
you could just make a regular CSS file
use media queries as you normally would
and then pull it into the file which
we're not doing here are we doing it yep
we're doing it here so you can see we
are pulling in a regular CSS file into
our component and in this manner as well
so and these aren't the only ways to do
it there are a ton of different ways to
do CSS within JavaScript for react so
these are just two ways that we happen
to be doing it on this project so
they're you know I'm sure if you if you
search for to talk to other people
you'll find a lot of other ways to do it
as well so my timer is up for now so
we're gonna do one more Pomodoro session
I'd say no matter what this is gonna be
our final Pomodoro session so whether or
not I get this to work we'll just we'll
just end it then because it's it starts
to be a really long stream and I'm sure
it's okay for you all you could all
could handle it at least you can handle
the code I don't know if you had me
talking that long but it starts to get
really tiring for me and my brain just
gives like too much so I know I'm gonna
be no good after another Pomodoro
session
of streaming
all right so let's start up our timer
for one more Pomodoro session and now
let's let's check out a regular
expression see what I messed up with
this and figure out what I need to do so
I'm gonna copy this regular expression
over to one of these services that lets
you test your regular expressions let's
see let me see if I can just get a new
one well what's that one somebody put in
a latch at the URL to another one good I
think I've used that other one regex
101.com
let's try that one
nope not brazier is eggs
All Right see here's our regular
expression and then let's let's pull in
let's bring in our data to test with and
it matched what what the heck it words
what is going on alright so which part
let me let me go check this error
message again
Oh Phoenix just got here said there's no
notification for the stream I don't know
what happened with that I'm really sorry
you didn't get a notification I started
in early this morning I scheduled it so
that I was hoping all the notifications
would go out so really sorry about that
let's see I'll use an explanation
alright so the first part matches the
character list view image literally
case-sensitive which is what we want
this question as matches the remainder
of the pattern with the following
effective flag s modifier use single
line dot matches new line characters
first capture group matches any
character quantifier matches between
zero and unlimited times as many times
as possible okay this matches the
character literally case sensitive case
sensitive list image you literally could
sense it okay Group one match okay
John Hanson says JavaScript flavor oh
okay good that was that was a very good
idea there I was not using the
JavaScript style of regex so I can't use
this question mark hmm all right well
let's change machine C strings DDoS good
I just read is up
all right so the look ahead doesn't work
so you want to capture him at you cow
for change to capture your Shima cash
inside the parentheses okay let's try
this
well that was easy okay okay let's see
what happens now cannot reap any match
of undefined hmm all right what am i
doing probably shouldn't be now that's
not what I want that's when they didn't
work
Oh hold on a second match I need to do
should work shrink up match there should
be content match and then okay
sit sing can't reprimand fine
saying content is undefined
all right let's try like that
let me see
let me make sure faculty lists are we
passing in so we are passing content
let's make sure
it is zero known faculty edges
it's
I want to see what the data structures
that we're getting in here so let's go
in dev tools and I'll make this bigger
and let's go into reader now I'm not
using Redux so not have
I thought I had Apollo dev tools hooked
up here but I guess not
trying to find where content is there we
go Michael
you're you thinking the same thing as
I'm sorry I haven't been I've been quiet
what I'm thinking is the we're not
actually getting the correct data so our
regular expression and our match our dot
match can't work because there's nothing
there for it to work on so I want to
figure out what the data structure is I
was hoping I could easily find it here I
was actually hoping that I had Apollo
dev tools I don't know why I don't have
it and I can't find where the data is
I guess I could let me go within the
component and see
okay so there's nothing so this content
faculty node content said that this is
not being cast down as a prop so we get
the profile link profile name but
nothing is here so I think yeah there's
there's a problem there so in a page
where we are using the content data this
props data type edges zero that's the
content so it's not listed so that's
that's the problem so up here we have
snowed faculty edges
zero all right so let's let's say I put
edges zero here hopefully it won't mess
everything up but let's see if this
would make a difference
faculty data dot map is not a function
okay so that's it's not working there
I guess I could just look it up here as
I said this extension alright so am I'm
not actually getting the content haha
alright let's double check this ha ha
I'm not bringing in that piece of data
that's what it doesn't exist
alright okay then let's let's look at
exactly how I brought this in here I I
titled slow content okay great
okay
and then down here hey there's our
content lots of it
hi let's take this and we'll say no
definitely do not want the content there
what I want there is the title and let's
I wonder if I still need that let's
let's try that the place is not a
function Shh
he's replacing on a function
see if I can do it this way
okay so that did work actually so we
could see where the content is it's
replaced and added this franciscan dot
e-d-u which is wonderful now let's let's
go in here and put our image in see if
that works and our title is still giving
us of course everything so let's do a
match let's get rid of all of this and
let's match for title yay check that out
okay so we have this professor share of
English okay works but you know we
actually don't want a title tag in the
middle of our HTML right because saito
tags have a meaning in HTML we don't
want it to be that so let's let's grab
this and let's add this here and first
we're gonna replace title
so what we'll do is instead of just
having title tags we're going to take
out the type of tags replace them with
div tags and then put in the class of
title and then
let's see I guess I'll have to change
this up
let's see if I can switch it didn't let
me switch the order but let's see if we
can switch the order this time let's see
what's going on with this lists you
image probably what's happening here is
I see
yeah let's just put in a div and we'll
just say actually let's do this
image
No okay I said you need to do this
differently just put this here and then
let's let's take this and make this what
we need to match and with this let's
just switch that to death so you know
alright cool we have images whoa we have
different sized images alright see so I
I had mentioned I that the images had to
be input correctly so obviously there
are different sized images here so let's
change it up and use the large size
image for everyone since this is amazing
all also we need to change how we input
this this title so let's use detail view
image instead so instead of ListView
image we use detailed view image and
then with our title we want to add in a
dangerously set in our HTML in here in
our typography
we can do that I don't know if I've ever
tried to do that in a typography
component let's see see if we can do it
what what what what what did we just do
okay
evidently I messed something up oh yeah
I put content instead of title there we
go
Wow what what is happening what did I do
let's see
okay so that's detail view image there
should be only one
all right
what I'm doing is getting displayed
twice okay this isn't anything what is
happening all right what if I what am i
doing that displays this twice
I did something wrong what did I do
hmmm not exactly sure what I did I
wasn't getting devil images before
somehow I'm getting them now
not sure what changed
what cheese
I don't know I can't see it
Michael s why does that one image have a
details list image tag in dev tools yeah
I don't understand
just one has it it's the same image
and then it's there's a comma in between
here and a comma in between these as
well so we have the div with the class
professor of English and then we
actually have professor English at the
end oh I see what's happening okay okay
all right here's what we need to do
match see image is
all right let's see that yeah there we
go
still Wow these images are I might have
to change my we might have to change
this layout like I can't like the size
of these images are 200 by 300 pixels
and this is the details view which means
they're the bigger image so if all I get
is 2 by 3 I have 200 pixels wide we may
need to go back to a list view or at
least we got to change this I'm not
gonna do it right now in today's stream
but we got to work with the images that
we have and right now we have small
images so if this is the images we have
to work with and we need to adjust our
cards we obviously can't shrink the card
all the way down to this image there
wouldn't be enough room for the text
that way it would look really weird
right we I don't want to have stuff on a
bunch of different lines it would be
okay for this section I suppose but I
don't want the titles going on two
different lines so I mean I guess I
could let's just try it let's try it and
then I don't think I would like it
though so where's our cards
I'm gonna fix all right let's just say
max width is 200 pixels okay so that
shrinks all our cards down I mean what
do you all think like a card this size I
don't know about it I mean I could maybe
try to reduce the padding it would be a
little better you know and then maybe go
one two three four like four across so
would it be better to do that it would
be better to have basically rows with
the image name title link and then the
image is here I'll let you all have some
time to let me know what you think about
that idea and right now I'm gonna scroll
back up to where I left off in the in
the chat I'm gonna answer some questions
and then once I get down to the bottom
out I'll see what you all think about
that that'll determine what I do next
with these with these cards and then I
will I'm not gonna change it right now
I'll commit this and then once I'm done
streaming maybe I'll get something to
eat because my stomachs growling sorry
if you all heard that hum and then I
need to get back to you data transfer so
I'll be doing that the rest of the day
okay so
Phoenix is Oh No
I'm a whole hour ahead of the live chat
let me show that this dream has been
we're coming up on two hours Wow since
the stream is going on so long I'm gonna
try to just read the questions maybe a
comment or two of course I will look at
them all I'm just not gonna read them
all out loud just to save a bit of time
John Henson says do you get some or
maybe too many unresolved coding
problems haunting you to try to sleep at
night coding seems to embed itself in
one's gray matter yeah it depends so if
I do if I have a problem that I can't
figure out and I've worked on it for a
really long time I still didn't figure
it out it does bother me especially if I
like I'm out of ideas occasionally I
will code in my sleep sometimes I come
up with good ideas from my sleep coding
and I mean like I dream about coding I
don't actually get up and start coding
so sometimes in my dreams I figure out
something sometimes it actually works if
I try it when I'm awake yeah but lately
I've been I've been okay I haven't
really been worrying too much about any
code
Matthew says do you have to use
metaprogramming at all things like
symbols proxies and reflection no I
don't and I haven't really heard that
much about it so I don't know what I'm
kind of interested to know more about it
though but I don't use it
let's see
Christian says well if you keep this up
with a healthy eating you will find out
eating sweets is not that tasty yeah I
long time ago before I was married maybe
like 1314 years ago I was on a diet
where I didn't have anything sweet like
not even hurt or anything for a long
time and then when I finally did eat
something actually I drank a half a can
of Mountain Dew and I was sick like my
stomach hurts so bad so I'm not to that
point yet so I actually had a milkshake
at the Google conference on Tuesday and
it didn't make me sick my you know the
my the next morning I felt I felt sick I
did not have as much energy my stomach
hurt like so I definitely felt the
effects of because I didn't just have a
milkshake I got a milkshake I had some
gummy worms and I had a mini cupcake so
I it was a one a little overboard but
miraculously I still didn't go over on
my calorie count so I don't know how
that happened I guess I just didn't eat
that much the rest of the day Frankie
says we like your style Jesse Thank You
Frankie whoa Orson says we have 37 users
and JavaScript AF sweets
that's awesome okay so I got to the
point where ever my I asked you all to
remind me if you wanted to link to my
wife's coding blog I will get you that
link right now let me check
let me figure out it's only github
profile so I'm like I pre sure I
remember where the username is but let
me double-check
I did I submitted some pull requests or
at least one pull request to it so it
should be on my activity scroll through
my activity on get up and find it there
we go
so Toby
there we go all right so I'm gonna let
me face this over here y'all can see it
and then I'll paste it in the chat so it
is Becca
so Bek a hhw so it's two H's in a row
got github do and that is her blog and
she built that using jest no not just
Jekyll justice for testing she built it
using Jekyll and then did the theme it's
not a premade theme so she did all that
CSS and everything herself
which really cool so I only helped
slightly and you can see what I helped
that if you check out the github repo
you could see what-what I committed and
what she committed and I did very little
so really proud of her and she's a good
writer I mean she's a writer first and
she's been writing for a long time so
it's cool blogging's not really my thing
I prefer to do the video stuff but she
does a good job with the blah
John Hanson s if all the cards were
links let's see you know the cards
themselves are not links just the button
just the button which I think that's how
I want it maybe I'll make the image a
link I think I'd be okay with that but
I'd like to keep this part not a link in
case someone wants to copy and paste a
name or a title and you know what I
think it'd be better if it should showed
a regular name instead of like last name
comma Oh what to figure out if there's a
way to change that without having to do
it manually just kind of automatically
switch the order I think that might be
maybe better hmm I think there is a way
so I keep yawning you two need to drink
my GP over here
i nee ki says to slightly hijack the
blob blog topic I'm writing a blog post
about setting up a dev environment from
scratch what else would you all like to
be covered first part online already
alright cool everybody let let leaky
Niki know if you haven't already in the
chat that sounds cool I don't know if
you think about it I'll let you know if
I think of something Niki I'm starting
to get super hungry so I wonder I don't
want to like think too much about it
right now and take up more time in the
stream but I will let you know if I
think you saw this
oh okay so I'm seeing now the mentioning
using so Michael says you could use
something like cheerio to scrape a text
source source oh says can you use
something like cheerio to scrape text
source code and Harshit says you could
use cheerio and the migration scripts so
okay maybe I'll have to look into that
you know what so much of the data has
already been migrated though yeah I
don't know at this point I don't want to
go back and redo a bunch of the data
that might actually take longer all
right maybe I'll look into it I have to
see if if I can still use it at this
point
Tech battle says hi hey how's it going
thanks for watching
okay earlier I was talking about
LinkedIn showing who was hired to that
company like what school air from and
Christian is confirmed that that that is
what LinkedIn does michael says Jesse I
saw your tweet about Apollo hiring if
only I was better that would be a dream
job yeah the the job with Apollo if you
all don't follow me on Twitter at least
you can follow me if you want to but
otherwise check out my profile I think
there's a link in the description or
maybe on my youtube page there's a link
I recently retweeted a link from someone
that works at Apollo saying Apollo's
hiring I think several positions but you
can work remotely and it seems like a
really cool place to work with Apollo is
like what we're using to help us out
with some graph QL stuff here so you
will be working on Apollo engine doing
react stuff and well if you decided to
do like the developer there's a couple
other positions I believe that are open
so I think it's cool I actually thought
about applying
self because I like a PO I use Apollo it
would be cool but I already applied to a
job at Apollo a while ago and I'm not
sure if it was the same job or not
I mean I guess it can't hurt to do it
again so but anyway if anybody's
interested you should apply it Michael I
say why not apply I mean even if you
don't think that you're experienced
enough to do it you never know if if the
application process you know isn't that
hard to do which I don't think it is
then you know give it a shot you know if
you you know even if you get an
interview and you don't get the job it's
still great practice
Faro spar wheel I'm not sure how to
pronounce that but correct me if I'm
wrong it says how experience must you be
to start a project and react I know the
basics of HTML CSS and JavaScript you
know what I recommend using something
called create react app to get started
that'll help you it'll basically set up
an entire working react project and then
you just go in and edit what you can't
and that's a great way to start so you
you basically start with something that
already works and you just play around
with it so start with that and then just
kind of work your way up in terms of
being able to add more functionality to
it but I mean if you already know basics
HTML CSS and JavaScript then I say go
for it you'll probably know pretty quick
whether it's you don't know enough you
know if you can't get anything to work
then I don't know maybe you might want
to do a little bit more learning but
some of the best learning is just
jumping in and encoding and trying it
out
spoil says is this just plain react yes
I mean we have a lot other stuff so this
is next j/s that we've used to create
our react app so we are using some
things that are next I mean we have
materia I as well that we're using so we
have a lot of the stuff we're using
Apollo for graph QL so we have a lot of
other stuff going on so I mean in terms
of is it just plain react I don't know
that we ever just use plain reacts we
always have other stuff in on the
projects but you know these these are
react components and material is just a
library of react components so even what
Apollo gives us is you know basically
react components to use that we can
query data
alright Phoenix says hey Jesse just
wanted to tell you that streaming works
totally fine on my laptop I even tried a
test stream with code audio and camera
input work just fine the only problem is
that I look horrible in from the camera
I might scare people with ha ha let's
say that I mean if you really don't want
your face on the camera you can just
show your screen for all of my early
streams I didn't show my face because I
thought like nobody wants to see me
right and then later on what I did find
out from I think I read it and then I
also I'm pretty sure that Quincy and Bo
talked about it as well we did a Skype
kind of group chat and we're saying that
it's better to show your face
essentially it's easier for people to
understand you if they can see your
facial expressions as you talk and then
even beyond that it's you develop better
relationships with your audience if they
can see you so I thought okay well I
need to just get over my not wanting
anybody to see me and and just do it so
I I do like now I'm very used to it
and I like it at first I was kind of
nervous and I'm like are there any like
weird things that I do all the time that
I don't even realize and everybody's
going to see it and nobody's brought
anything up so I guess I I don't but I
don't know it just entirely depends I
think it you know there's enough to try
to worry about when you first start out
that it maybe it is better to not show
your face and just do your screen but
it's it's definitely up to you but I'm
glad that you got it all working though
Michael's two columns in the card
instead of two rows we were you thinking
like
leave leave the card sir you saying the
image would be one column and then the
content be another column I'm not sure I
wonder see these aren't even the same
dimensions
yeah I'm not I I don't know but it's
gonna take some work
yeah I'm gonna have to rethink a little
bit about how we've done this it just
needs to be able to look okay with
images of different shapes and sizes
because evidently that's what we have to
work with
[Music]
Phoenix saying could you make the image
set with 100% I could do that but the
problem would be then that these images
are not large enough so they would look
pixelated because we would be stretching
them past their their natural width
Michael said you could set the image of
the the width max in a max width of the
image to entitle to 50% so their line
image with position and the other
secondary text next to it then below
them both props name across : oh yeah
I'm gonna have to try out some different
things albert asks how much would you
charge your project that would only take
you like at most three days I have an
idea for a nice little website done and
react firebase cloud and stripe I don't
know so I guess the first thing is like
a project that would only take three
days I want it like I would I prefer to
break it down by more like by hour if
possible because I find that to be more
accurate also in general and this is for
any bug when you go to take a project
assume you're gonna work on it a lot
more than you a first estimate but maybe
after you if you've been working for a
long time you get really good at
estimating then it'll be okay but
generally like at least double how many
hours you think it's gonna take and then
consider like how much is my time really
worth so at at this point I'm very busy
so I know like any extra time that I
take is gonna be time away from my kids
it's gonna make my wife really upset
because that means she is gonna have to
not be able to do
she wants to do because she's gonna have
to watch all the kids and make sure that
I have the you know the time to do the
work so in fact during all of that in
I'm gonna say like basically I'm I'm not
interested in doing any work for you
know anything less than I don't let's
just say to make it a nice number a
hundred dollars an hour one hundred US
dollars right because it's just gonna be
a lot it's gonna be a lot more stress a
lot to deal with like you know
potentially depending on the deadline
like it could mess with my exercise
schedule and I mean there's just a lot I
plan on having to work overtime right
now at work anyway from my project so
that's what I'm saying so let's say a
project is going to take three days
let's assume I only worked eight hours a
day on that project which is like a
normal workday so what that's 20 18 24
yeah 24 I can't do basic math on live
streaming so let's just call it let's
just say $50 or 50 hours let's assume
I'm going to take 50 hours to do this
project in reality then at $100 an hour
like there's there's your price right so
yeah so I mean that's that's what it is
and I think people sometimes are shocked
by the price of these types of projects
but realistically like it's it's highly
skilled work and especially if it's work
on top of what somebody's already doing
then you gotta value that more I mean
even at least here in the United States
even like government workers who are
doing manual labor which I was doing I
did that for six years
just manual labor work for the
government and you know when we would
work overtime we got paid we call it a
time and a half so like if I made let's
say you know five dollars an hour then I
would make seven dollars and fifty cents
an hour when I got into overtime
so like that extra time is the set is
worth more so anyway that's my answer my
long answer to that question is
realistically I would probably charge
five thousand dollars for site even if
you think it's only gonna take three
days I guarantee it will take more than
three days and now like I said that's
assuming we're talking eight hours a day
for three days right that's you know if
we're really talking like okay I'm gonna
work two hours on it every day and it's
only gonna take three days then it's a
lot less money right but yeah and that's
me - there may be other people that are
in a different situation
may be willing to take a lot less when I
had a lot less experience like five
years ago like five years ago when I
started out I started before I didn't I
knew barely anything I knew like no
JavaScript very very basic CSS and HTML
I worked for $10 an hour I didn't stay
at $10 an hour for very long maybe like
the first three months I was willing to
work for $10 an hour after that I was
never willing to work for that again but
that that's how I started so I certainly
was not as good I couldn't do this stuff
then and it took me way longer to do the
same thing so that's it's kind of
another thing like you can always find
somebody cheaper and depending on what
you want that may be fine but you know
you should realize one you're not gonna
get as good of a product and it's going
to take that person longer so if you are
paying them by the hour realize that
it's going to take them longer you
so there's just so many factors that go
into that and so when you're trying to
price your your labor like really think
about what like realistically what is it
gonna mean for your lifestyle and for
your family or you know your friends you
know whoever is close to you what is
that gonna mean for them
what kind of hardship is that gonna be
for them and and price accordingly the
other way to price is how much value am
I going to add to this company or this
product and that's certainly a good
price so for you
you can think of how much you need to
get paid but when you're explaining it
to a client explain it in terms of how
much money am I gonna make for you when
this product goes live or how much money
will you save when I do these
improvements things like that
so I wouldn't go in to a client and
explain like what I just said to you you
know in terms of well my wife is gonna
have to watch the kids and all this
stuff clients if they're nice people
they might care but it doesn't really
matter to their business what they want
to hear is how is this gonna make me
more money how is it going to make my
the lives of my workers or my clients
easier
how's it gonna make me more efficient at
what I do things like that
Michael Carrillo says forgetting your
wife's github username is worse than
forgetting her birthday haha I'm gonna
tell that to my wife and see what she
says
Phoenix says Becca is your wife she is
one of my fave moms who code Twitter
handles I never knew this until now
coder family goes no way she'll be so
happy when I tell her that she was
actually really discouraged this morning
I gave her like a pep talk well part of
the reason she was too scared she was
mad at me over me not letting her have
enough time to code but then also she
was discouraged in thinking like that
she wouldn't be able to get a job too so
stuff like that will really help keep
her keep her positive so I mean I have
my own issues with depression that get
me down but she's working through things
too like I'm not gonna give all her
details away whatever you know if she
wants to discuss things on her blog
that's fine but like essentially like
she's dealing with issues from traumatic
things that happened regarding like the
birth of our last child and so that
that's still affecting her both mentally
and physically so comments like that to
my wife I think really really helped her
so if anybody does know my wife you
follow her on Twitter or anything like
that please make sure you you know let
her know if you appreciate what she's
doing because you know sometimes she
needs some encouragement
we all need encouragement you know
Frankie says blogging it's or the new
magazines of our time oh yeah for short
they need to make it's amazing anybody
can set up a blog you know basically for
nothing and yeah it's it's just it's
great I mean there's it's hard to find
like is this person worth reading I
don't want to say that people aren't
worth reading but like you know what I
mean like figuring out who really is an
expert on what you're trying to find out
you know everybody's story has value but
there's only so much time in the day so
you're gonna find what's right but it is
amazing that everybody has oh my a lot I
shouldn't say everybody there are people
that don't have access to the Internet
and things like that but a lot of people
have the ability to express themselves
like that and that's that's just awesome
so trying to get through this live chat
all John says nikki has some great
well-written content on his blog I'll
need to check it out - all right yeah
for sure what was I thought I saw him
put the link to that in the in the chat
off to scroll back through later on and
find it and check it out cuz I haven't
seen it yet
Aniki says I thought of something I can
add browser extensions that are handy
for developers yeah that's a great idea
all right Matthew says got a passing
grade on my first front-end nanodegree
project awesome so cool I'm very happy
for you congratulations that's cool my
wife I think just turned in her first
project as well so I don't know if she
got feedback yet she may have gotten it
today while I'm working and I didn't
hear about it yet but really cool Jones
says if those cars are styled as display
flex the width is determined from the
image with yet but you know what John I
think since the image is in that
container that we brought in from the
original markup I think it's messing
it's messing that up also we I modified
those cards as well so if maybe if I go
back to doing a CSS background image so
and use the card basically as intended
by materialized or material UI maybe
it'll solve so I there's a lot of
different things I want to try so we'll
see how it goes I don't know if I'll
spend another stream on this or not it
might start to get boring but we'll see
I'll definitely show you all what the
end result is and if I forget to show
you just remind me world session the
names on the card start with dr. yes for
sure for sure they should
Matthew says that's good advice my
personal deadlines are always off yeah I
assume you were talking about doubling
the amount of time you think it's going
to take yeah and I recommend when you're
working on projects keep track of how
long everything takes you you know like
monitor your Pomodoro sessions things
like that and that will help you to
estimate later on yeah you can you can
look back on previous projects and see
like okay when I did this very similar
thing it took me this long you know it's
hard to just remember that you know when
when a client asked like how long is
this gonna take
I'm it's almost impossible to accurately
just rattle off a number you know you
really need to go back in and study the
data that you've already you know
collected that you already put for each
project for the amount of time how much
it actually takes you to work on it and
then base your estimates off of that and
even then I would I would estimate a
little more like if you intend to do
anything new then it's going to take you
longer than you think to really learn it
world says who makes $5 an hour let me
when I started working the first year I
ever worked I worked for the city
government and from the city I grew up
in which is weird in West Virginia I
worked for four dollars and seventy five
cents an hour and that was what I made
and I'm not gonna lie before that was
actually before I could legally work so
I had to get paid in cash I did work in
some places where I made $2 an hour so
it definitely happens it happens people
work for that and I'm sure there are
people that worked for way less than
that still
all right Albert says thanks I'll hit
you up with more details to see how much
our you think it's going to take for the
website yeah no problem
Tyron it's Tyr oh and I'm not sure if
I'm pronouncing that right but anyway
they say I know some JavaScript and I
want to break into JavaScript frameworks
etc but I just don't feel confident
enough yet what are your thoughts that
may help I'm gonna say kind of a similar
answer that I gave earlier in the stream
just try it out use create react app do
like an intro a demo to react even the
react documentation I believe starts you
out with a really basic intro project
and I think they use create react app
for that if you're not familiar with
what that is it's just something that
helps you get started working with react
and it actually starts you off with a
complete working react project that's
just very basic like a hello world
you know project and so you start with
something that already works and you can
edit that so I find that very helpful
just you know just start see how you
like it see if it's too overwhelming for
you you can always do something else but
you know I would say don't don't think
about it too much in terms of like
wondering about it you know just jump in
do some code like the only what are you
going to lose you're gonna lose a little
bit space on your computer for when you
download all those node modules right
and that's it and if that's not your
thing you can always just delete it and
move on you know you'll you'll miss
you'll lose out on a few hours of your
life I guess but I'd say just go for it
alright and Matthew said thanks Jess
you're welcome no problem
all right finally got to the end of the
chat this has been nearly two and a half
hours of live stream Oh awesome I did
pronounce them correctly I'm alright I'm
really happy and for anybody if I ever
do pronounce your name incorrectly
please let me know I I would I really
want to be respectful of how you want
your net your name to be pronounced so
let me know it's it's not an
inconvenience for me at all to be
corrected I definitely I want that so
alright finally I'm gonna go get
something to eat
[Music]
what's today alright so Mars Friday so
us for Friday tomorrow I'll be working
from home oh I'm gonna do my best to try
to stream I'm not gonna lie when I work
from home it's always harder to to
shrink for some reason well number one
the streams don't go as well because I
don't have as good of internet or
equipment but also like it's more
comfortable at home and when you're
comfortable it's easier to stay
comfortable and just keep on coding and
not like you start to do something else
like like streaming so anyway but I'm
gonna do my best to try to stream
tomorrow I'll let you all know on
Twitter on Instagram and through the
notifications on YouTube if they work
what time I will stream and so and so
then have a wonderful day